hey youtubers it's Charlie this is gonna
be my flash episode 17 video whole lotta
mark hamill whole lot of reverse flash I
know you guys all have really big
questions about the WTF reveal like the
big reverse flash stuff in this episode
so I'm gonna start with that and then
I'll do my top 5 moments so just careful
for spoilers if you haven't seen the
episode yet I've already seen a lot of
comments from you guys so this is what's
going on there is still one reverse
flash on the show it's a Oh Bart Thawne
but you can think of it as being one
person in two different bodies he
basically absorbed Harrison wells DNA so
that he could become him on the genetic
level but retain all of the aspects of
himself as a abarth on so that he could
still tap into the Speed Force
interesting to note that he ran out so
to speak of Speed Force when he was
fighting with Barry Allen in the past
they haven't fully explained it on the
show yet I'm hoping they do before the
end of the season but the per first
flash doesn't tap into the Speed Force
in the same way that the flash does he
taps into the negative Speed Force which
is a different thing but for all intents
and purposes the Harrison wells that you
saw in the flashback was a totally
different character think of him as like
Harrison wells prime very eclectic nice
scientist looking forward to building
STAR Labs in the future based on what
air bar Don said whenever Harrison wells
has been talking to Gideon the computer
looking at the newspaper from the future
that's the date that Harrison wells
originally built the particle
accelerator in the accident created
Barry Allen Hale Barth on the
reverse-flash came back in time killed
Barry's mother and then said I need that
to happen a little bit sooner than
expected and then he took on Harrison
wells persona I don't know how the
show's gonna treat the mythology of the
Speed Force because it gets a little
crazy in the comics but because they
just said the words Speed Force on the
show I don't think they're gonna explain
the negative Speed Force for a while if
you guys have read flash rebirth let me
know do you think that they're going to
incorporate the negative Speed Force or
do you think they're just gonna simplify
it all regardless of what they do the
big takeaway is is that Harrison wells
is really more like a Oh Barth on
wearing Harrison wells as a meat suit I
know this raises a whole lot more
questions now because of the way the
Flash's relationship with Eddie Thawne
has changed Eddie Thawne is still like
the great great grandfather of aerobar
Thawne but here we go getting in the top
number-5 reverse-flash flashbacks so we
get a slow-mo of the night that Barry's
mom died we get to see them like jumping
around punching the out of each
other
it doesn't fully explain what's going on
it's just meant to reveal that a Oh Bart
Thawne was not Harrison wells like
they're two different people although
technically on the show they look like
the same person in present-day I have no
idea how they're gonna incorporate that
other actor into the show we might just
see him in flashbacks and flash-forwards
although technically a flash-forward
would be a flashback because he was in
the future and then traveled back to the
past I know it sounds kind of funny when
you think about it that way in the
comics there been a couple times where
they devote like single issues to
explaining the reverse flashes backstory
like a Oh Bart Dawn's backstory so once
in future flash is really good read and
the prelude to flashpoint are both
really good l bars on explainers moving
on to number four meet the tricksters he
was answering questions on Twitter
during the episode someone asked him you
know is this your character from the
original flash series is that in
continuity he said kind of but if it's
in continuity just assume that there was
no flash during his era but he actually
started in two episodes of the original
series there was there was only one
season two that the younger trickster is
the Axl Walker trickster obviously they
had that really funny Easter egg where
he's like I am your father
that Darth Vader Empire Strikes Back
moment that that was so awesome
that's bending continuity just a little
bit from the comics in the comics takes
the mantle of the trickster and tries to
start committing crimes James Jesse gets
pissed takes back all his stuff beats
the out of Axl Walker and says
never use my name again so early in the
episode when Mark Hamill gets really
pissed off that's accurate to the comics
the TV show just made best use of their
Jedi Master while they had him if we
ever see a trickster again it'll
probably be the Axl Walker trickster
he'll probably come back on the show and
just because I don't think Mark Hamill's
coming back before the end of the season
doesn't mean he won't ever come back in
season two or season three he said that
he mostly came back so that he could
work with John Wesley Shipp again which
is really touching and they actually
they used some of the music cues from
his original appearance on the classic
series so like whenever he's on screen
they have like some classic trickster
music in the background you could barely
hear it they even had his original
costume in his lair
the original costume he wore on the 90
series or actually is probably
recreation moving at number three team
flash protects iris this is really cool
Barry reveals himself to two new people
including his dad you always did look
good in red it was also really cool that
they brought him back to STAR Labs just
you know like nice omage to the original
series if he never watched the original
series
Amanda pay's was kind of like the
Harrison wells of that show like the
scientist that helped him out actually
maybe it's better to call her the
Caitlin snow of that show because they
had something of a ship going on and she
was not also secretly the reverse-flash
the Eddie Thawne reveal also really big
but more of like a WTF way just a look
on his face you could feel like a giant
fish in his mouth like that's how much
is jaw dropped and remember because
Barry changed the timeline they're still
totally BFFs if you have read the comics
I do feel like they're pushing Eddie
Thawne in a hunter so lamont direction
so I always knew at some point he would
learn who Barry is because in the comics
hunter and Wally West are good friends
and hunter knows that Wally West is the
flash I may have mentioned it before but
the TV series the flash show is blending
the Wally West and the Barry Allen
storylines so if you want to read the
comic so you have to like look back to
Barry Allen stuff and you have to read
the Wally West stuff which is basically
like Geoff Johns run Eddie Thawne seems
like he's totally on board with what
Barry Allen and Joe are doing like he
totally buys into it what we should
really be worried about is how much he's
been appearing with Harrison wells in
these pictures or Tom Cavanagh who we
now know is a Oh Bart Thawne what I
think is gonna end up happening is is a
Oh Bart Thawne will try to start
manipulating Eddie and Eddie will become
collateral damage either through mind
control from Grodd or from rainbow
Raider who we actually saw in the
trailer after the episode if you have
read the comics and you know what
happens to hunter zolomon just please
use spoiler tags moving on to number two
eobard thawne teaches Barry how to phase
this is the really awesome spectacle of
the episode I think we all knew it was
gonna happen at some point the flash has
been able to phase through stuff since
the classic comics running through
something is just one way to get that
armband off he could have just vibrated
his wrist really fast but it wouldn't
have looked nearly as cool and that
speech the Tom Cavanagh had that is my
new favorite speech all season long just
replay that speech over and over it's
almost like a
Bart dawn is in love with the speedforce
like those two should go off and get a
room grant gustin said like outside of
the episode that this was probably one
of Tom Cavanagh best performances in an
episode
he was also referring to him playing the
different version of his character in
the flashbacks before he'd had all his
DNA sucked out and finally my number one
WTF moment eh Oh Bart Thawne drinks
Harrison wells like he's a milkshake
make as many paul thomas anderson jokes
as you want
milkshakes being drunk all over the
place Speed Force milkshakes DNA
milkshakes I heard a couple journalists
using the term genetic camouflage so
that might be the official line from the
flash writers room like what a Oh Bart
thon is doing just calling it genetic
camouflage in case you didn't catch it
too he kind of reused the line whenever
he killed Cisco in episode 15 to me your
wife has been dead for centuries that
was just what he said to Cisco I'm sorry
but to me you've been dead for centuries
here's my big question for you guys now
that we know the Al Barth aunt is
wearing a Harrison wells meat suit and
we've gotten some flashbacks do you
think we're gonna see a flash-forward or
like I guess a flashback to when AO bar
thought was in the future I did I feel
like they need to tell the story about
why he originally came back and needed
to kill Barry Allen's mother even though
that's been in the comics for a long
time the show's designed so that people
who don't read the comics can follow it
so they just they need to keep
explaining air bar Thawne we're only
about halfway there and just to be clear
the 2020 date on the newspaper is when
the flash was first created the reverse
flash came back in time and jump-started
it sooner al bar thought himself is from
the 25th century which is much much much
further in the future some of the really
cool things that I may not have
mentioned in my trailer video we see
Grant Gustin in the secret lair so he
finds out about the Gideon computer
eventually I've already talked about Roz
Amell and the firestorm team up but what
I really want to know is what is the
reverse-flash gonna try and do with all
the metahumans that they've locked up
is he gonna unleash them all and just
cause a bunch of chaos as a distraction
while he does something else or is he
going to try and tap into their energy
somehow if you guys ever read the crisis
on Infinite Earths the anti-monitor
actually hooked up a bunch of
superheroes
two giant machines so you know in my
fantasy they have like a scene like that
where you have like all these metahumans
plugged into this giant reverse-flash
machine I don't think that's gonna
happen though that that's just like
wishful thinking so don't forget new
episode of arrow tomorrow the schedule
is a little wonky so when we see arrow
tomorrow it will technically be taking
place after next week's episode of the
flash it's a little bit weird because
it's like they're like one episode apart
but I'll try and explain again whenever
I post my arrow video in case you
haven't seen it yet you can click here
for the finale trailer for like the
trailer with footage from the rest of
the episodes and you can click here to
learn all about the Deadpool movie thank
you so much watching everybody let's
high five I'll see you guys tomorrow
you